let's do some problems that deal with
equations and inequalities so let's
start with this problem two here so it
says define the variables and translate
the following expressions into
inequalities
so see part a a bus can seat 65
passengers or fewer so in part a
let's let
let x
be
the number
bus
conceit
you can see so the number of people you
can fit in the bucks bus we're going to
call that x and they're saying that the
bus can feed can fit 65 people or fewer
so x
so x
has to be less than or equal to
65 and we put that equal there that less
than or equal because it could be 65 it
doesn't say definitely less than 65 it
could be 65 passengers or fewer so
that's why it's less than or equal to
b
the sum of two consecutive integers is
less than 54. so if you say x
is
first
integer
and then x plus 1 is
the next
they're saying the sum of these two is
less than 54. so x
plus
x plus 1
is less than
54. and if you actually wanted to figure
out what x is what the first integer you
could just solve this inequality
c
an amount of money is invested at five
percent annual interest let x
be
the
amount
of money
it's invested at five percent annual
interest the interest earned at the end
of the year is greater than or equal to
two hundred fifty dollars so what's the
interest earned at the end of the year
it's the amount of money you invest
times your annual interest rate times
five percent or if you write it as a
decimal it's 0.05
so 0.05 or 5
times the amount of money invested
that is going to be
greater than
or equal to this is the amount of
interest earned
that is interest
interest earned
that is going to be a greater than or
equal to
250 dollars
so that's what we did we set up the
problem we into an inequality
and part d
part d
you buy hamburgers at a fast food
restaurant a hamburger costs 49 cents
you have at most three dollars to spend
write inequality for the number of
hamburgers you can buy
so let's let let's change the letters
let's h
be equal to the number
of hamburgers
so the total i'm going to spend is the
number of hamburgers
times the amount per hamburger times
0.49
that's the total amount i'm going to
spend and that can at most be three
dollars so it has to be less than or
equal
to three dollars less than or equal
to three dollars so that is
our inequality
let's do problem four here
problem 4
check that the given number is a
solution to the corresponding inequality
all right
part a here
so the inequality is 2 times x plus 6
is less than or equal to 8x
and they're saying that x is equal to 12
is a solution let's verify that so if
you put a 12 here get a different color
if this is a 12 and then this would be a
12.
so you get two times
twelve plus six so this is two times
eighteen
is less than or equal to eight times
twelve eight times twelve is ninety-six
2 times 18
is 36. so 36 is definitely less than or
equal to 96. so this x is equal to 12
is a solution
part b
b
we have
1.4
times z
plus 5.2
is greater than
0.4
z
and for the solution that z is equal to
minus nine
negative nine i should say obviously
minus nine the correct wording is
negative nine so let's put a negative
nine here so it's one point four
they're saying that that's one of the
solutions times negative 9
plus
5.2 is greater than 0.4
times
negative
negative
9. and i'm just going to use the
calculator on this one just for the sake
of time you could do that on your head
if you like
so we have
on the left hand side
1.4
times
9
times
negative 9
that's equal to minus 12.6 so this is
minus 12.6 plus 5.2
plus
5.2
is equal to negative 7.4
so this left-hand side
is negative 7.4
and then they're claiming that that is
greater than this i can do in my head 4
times 9
is
36 i'm going to have to put a negative
sign because the positive times a
negative and i have one number behind
the decimal point
so this is saying negative 7.4
is greater than
is greater than
negative 3.6 this isn't true
this isn't true if you draw a number
line right here
so if this is 0 this is negative 3.6
this is negative 7.4 it's less than
negative 3.6 so this is not true
i'm doing a
big red color that is not true
z is equal to negative 9 is not a
solution of this inequality right there
it does not satisfy
that inequality
part c
part c
they have minus five halves
minus five halves
y
plus one half
is less than negative eighteen and
they're claiming y is equal to forty is
a solution let's try that out
so minus 5 halves instead of y i can
write 40 just to see if it works
plus one half is less than minus 18
that's their claim
so 5 halves times 40 divide the
numerator and divide denominator by two
so one
becomes a twenty so it becomes minus
five times one is minus one hundred
plus one half is less than
minus eighteen well you could view this
as ninety-nine negative ninety-nine and
a half negative 99
and a half you could do that in your
head if you like or you could view this
as 99.5
you're adding 0.5 to minus 100
is less than
negative 18 which is definitely true
this is more negative than this is so
this is
correct
and then finally
finally part d
let me
scroll down or let me clear some space
for myself
part d
d
they're saying 80
is greater than or equal to 10
times three t plus two and they're
claiming that t is equal to 0.4 as a
solution let's try that out
80 is greater than or equal to
3 times 0.4 3 times 0.4
plus 2
so that's saying that 80 is greater than
or equal to 10 times 3 times 0 times 0.4
is 1.2
plus 2
or 80 is greater than or equal to 10
times this is
3.2
or
that 80
80 is greater than or equal to
32 which is absolutely right so d is
also
a valid solution
problem five
problem five the cost of a ford focus
is 27 percent of the price of a lexus
gs450h
all right if the price of a ford is
fifteen thousand dollars so the ford
is
is equal to fifteen
thousand dollars what is the price of
alexis so they tell us that the ford
that the ford is equal to 27 percent of
the price of the lexus is equal to
0.27 or 27
times the price of alexis
so we could just and i could write f and
l but i'll just write out the words
there
so the four we know is fifteen thousand
dollars so we know that fifteen
thousand dollars is equal to
twenty seven percent 0.27
times the price of a lexus
so to figure out the price of a lexus we
just divide both sides
by 0.27 0.27
and divide this side by 0.27
that just becomes a 1 and so you have
the price of your lexus
is equal to 15 000
divided by
0.27 see what we get
so let me clear it we have 15 one two
three fifteen thousand dollars
divided by
point two seven
is equal to
fifty five thousand five hundred fifty
five dollars and fifty five cents so
we'll say fifty five thousand five
hundred and fifty six dollars just round
up
so this is equal to fifty five thousand
five hundred and fifty
six dollars so you're spending a lot
more on the lexus than you would on the
ford focus it better be a much better
car
finally number six
on your new job you can be paid in one
of two ways
all right
you can either repaid so let's say this
is option one
option one
and let's write option two here
option two
you can either be paid one thousand
dollars per month plus six percent
commission of total sales
so let's let
let
s is equal to
total
sales so your first option you'll be
paid a thousand dollars per month plus
six percent of total sales
so on a monthly basis you'll be paid one
thousand dollars plus
six percent of total sales so plus six
percent
times
your total sales that's option one
that's
right there you can either pay one
thousand dollars per month plus six
percent commission of total sales
and then option two is
1200 per month let me switch colors
option 2 i'll do it in yellow
paid 1200 per month
so 1200 per month plus 5 percent
commission on sales over two thousand
dollars
so plus let me scroll over a little bit
plus five percent
of sales over two thousand dollars so if
my sales are s my sales over two
thousand dollars are going to be
s minus two thousand dollars
s minus two thousand dollars right if my
sales are let's say they're three
thousand dollars in a month the sales
over two thousand are going to be three
thousand
minus two thousand it's going to be one
thousand dollars over two thousand so
these are our two options
let me
let me
highlight that right over there
and they say for what amount of sales is
the first option better than the second
option and assume there are always sales
over two thousand dollars so they're
essentially saying okay this is always
going to be non-zero right here so we
want to know the situation where the
first option is better better probably
meaning for me meaning that i'll get
more money so when is option one going
to be we could either say greater than
or greater than equal to option two
and then we could solve this equation so
let's see what we can do the first thing
i might want to do is just
well let's let's do the first thing let
me subtract 1000 from both sides so if
you subtract 1000
from the left hand side you're just left
with 0.06
s
is greater than or equal to subtract a
thousand from the left hand side i'll
take the thousand from here you're left
with two hundred
plus zero point zero five times s minus
two thousand
and then
let's see i'll probably want to multiply
that out this is going to be 200
plus 0.05
s
minus
this 0.05 that's the same 5
that's the same thing as 1 20th
1 20th
of
2000 that's 100 so this is minus
100 that times that is 100 i'm just
distributing
this 5 percent or this .05
so that's the right hand side of the
equation and on the left-hand side we
have 0.06
and we just simplify
the right-hand side a little bit we have
200 minus 100 so that just becomes 200
minus 100 we could just write as plus
100
right there so our equation is 0.06
is greater than or equal to 0.05
oh sorry this is 0.06 s
is greater than or equal to i don't want
to lose that s over there
0.05 s
plus
100 now let's subtract
0.05 from s from both sides of the
equation so
0.06 minus 0.05 s is going to be
0.01 s
is greater than or equal to i subtracted
this from both sides so it's not going
to be here anymore
is greater than or equal to
100
and now i just divide both sides by 0.01
so 0.01
0.01 that becomes a 1
and then we are left with
s
is to be greater than or equal to what's
100 divided by 0.01 that's a hundred
this is a hundred divided by this the
same thing as 100 divided by one over
one hundred which is the same thing as a
hundred times a hundred
a hundred times a hundred is ten
thousand
so option one is definitely better for
you if your total sales for the month if
your total sales for the month
if s is greater than or equal to ten
thousand dollars if it's less than that
you're better with option two